what was racist about a poo here is a
brown man married to a beautiful brown
woman owns his own business selling
overpriced products to unwitting white
people
who is not racist he's the american
dream
[ __ ] i am number one and [ __ ] whoever
don't acknowledge it
hey why are you apologizing for laughing
bro look what we've done to white men
[Applause]
let that [ __ ] out bro you're allowed to
be happy
white men are like shelter dogs now
he's apologizing for laughing at a
comedy show isn't that [ __ ]
unbelievable
it's like watching reek and game of
thrones
going through the whole arc you guys
used to run [ __ ] big dicks swinging
everywhere well moderate-sized dicks
swinging everywhere
[ __ ] that dude i'ma be honest i don't
even believe in white male privilege
shut up
i'm waiting for you to shut the [ __ ] up
always say name one thing a white male
can't have okay an opinion
opinions are liberating i literally get
paid for mine
the second a white guy even starts to
have one the entire internet is like um
your privilege is showing
[Laughter]
maybe you should check your privilege
i hate that dude let a white guy express
himself
because if you don't they bottle up all
their feelings
and then they fester
and get real dark
and then they walk into a voting booth
every four years
and the rest of us are like how the [ __ ]
did this happen that's how
you didn't let them say anything
then one guy showed up and said
everything
and they were like that's my guy
[Applause]
it's like the dark knight for white
dudes
not the hero we need
the hero we deserve
i'll tell you another thing a white dude
can't have an excuse
let me tell you something white guy
if you fail
it is your fault
and i'ma tell you right now you look
like you've been through some [ __ ]
but nobody cares how much you struggle
it don't matter if you grew up in a
trailer park and your daddy beat you and
your mom was addicted to white people
crack
meth you guys know i'm talking about
meth right
ravaging middle america
kind of funny in a car make sense but
the point is
we just look at white men like their
cats we're like ah he'll land on his
feet
that sucks dude
there's freedom of being a minority the
freedom i have if i fail not only is it
not my fault it's still your [ __ ]
fault ain't that crazy
i'm not talking to all minorities i
understand
black americans have been taken
advantage of mistreated for centuries i
get that but when i see people who look
like me talking about white privilege
where were your parents
they didn't teach you about your
american privilege
i grew up in the 90s and i tried being
woke back when i was just lazy and
they set me straight
mom dad you know white people have jobs
indians can't access
they'd be like okay you know what you
have that real indians can't access
toilets
there's a lot of folks if you try to
describe toilets they would think it was
actual magic
they'd be like wait a minute hold on you
doo-doo into a machine
press a button
dude disappear
where does it go
[Music]
and you're so privileged you'd be like
honestly bro i never even thought about
it
part's unknown i guess
could have done that episode
we're so privileged we don't just got
toilets we got toilet paper
it's a lot of people don't got paper
paper
we got ass paper
and have you seen the adjectives we're
putting on this product
it's pretty privileged
no no quilted
extra absorbent
aloe and vitamin e
i am wiping my ass with blankets at this
point
triple ply
nutrient enriched blankets
how privileged we are dude my [ __ ]
gets more vitamins than the average
african adolescent
that's crazy
and we can talk about other people's
privilege get the [ __ ] out of here
this is how privileged we are as
americans if you go to your friend's
house and they got one-ply toilet paper
don't you start looking around like
did he lose his job
i understand why else would be relegated
to this government-issued product
i can't wipe my ass with this it feels
like paper
white privilege dawg i'm saying we're
lucky to be us
i'm not saying he can't cancel anybody i
think we're taking it a bit far
canceling mascots
come on
the washington redskins
if you really care about the native
americans you know
that the washington redskins mascot
isn't too offensive it's not offensive
enough
guys i thought this through
if you talk to people half of them will
tell you that native americans are
offended by the redskins mascot the
other half will tell you that they're
not and what i've realized is we're all
just guessing
because native americans are basically
human bitcoin
like i believe they exist
but i never got my hands on one of them
i've never seen one in the real world
but you forget how [ __ ] up that is
until you see a racist mascot so if you
really care about the native americans
you make all their mascots as offensive
as possible
as
reminders [ __ ] the washington redskins
they should be the washington white skin
heads
the chicago blackhawk lives don't matter
thanks black dude for laughing so hard
you really
you free up the rest of these guys to
let it out you know what i mean
they don't know it's okay
they didn't even let me get to the most
offensive name
the portland trail of tear blazing yeah
right that's pretty good
now you remember if you didn't think
about the trail of tears in fifth grade
and now you're like oh [ __ ] maybe we
should give them some reparations thank
you racist mascot
also if you know anything about sports
you want the redskins to have a racist
mascot
because this is a terrible team
so if there's any young kids thinking
about being racist they'll take one look
at that win-loss record and be like
never mind
wow clearly racism is for losers
god one playoff win in 30 years that's
embarrassing
that should be your punishment if you
have a bad team you have to have a
racist
mascot the cleveland browns
you think i want my skin associated with
that garbage franchise
absolutely not
you are the cleveland klansman until
further notice
grew up in the 90s i'm not used to
indians talking about racism
these [ __ ] got rid of a poo
how you gonna cancel a poo dog
i miss a pool you guys remember a pool
the indian guy that owned the
convenience store in the simpsons
he was a staple of my childhood and then
all of a sudden four brown dudes wanted
to [ __ ] white girls and try to make him
racist
and then they just canceled this
[ __ ]
what was racist about a poo here is a
brown man married to a beautiful brown
woman owns his own business selling
overpriced products to unwitting white
people
who is not racist he's the american
dream
[Applause]
the only thing that offended my parents
about a poo was i'm not a poo
i'd be like what about his accent
doesn't that offend you and they would
be like your accent offends me
have you heard yourself speak hindi it's
embarrassing
[Music]
man these [ __ ] brown a-list
millionaires
oh because of a poo i got made fun of in
my childhood
welcome to childhood
what do you [ __ ] this is with everybody
else you think they were carrying the
korean kid on their shoulders after
calculus
no they cheat on that [ __ ] and
then ignore him until the next pop quiz
the korean kid at my school didn't even
know his name you know what they called
him chinese that's right they didn't
care
[Applause]
thank god i had a poo for bullies to
make fun of
otherwise they would have made fun of me
for me i don't need that
5'7 i'm skinny fat i kind of sound like
steve buscemi
i get too many vulnerabilities but
luckily i had a poo to absorb all of
their insults like captain america
shield
so the worst thing a bully ever said to
me was thank you come again
oh teacher teacher
this kid is calling me polite
how will i recover
i heard they're gonna bring him back and
he's going to be voiced by an indian
dude
i gotta be honest
i don't want that
i want a pool voice by a white guy
don't woo [ __ ] make me feel away
let me explain first
because back in the day whenever some
racist redneck would be like these
[ __ ] indians are taking all our jobs
i could be like
[Applause]
not all of them
oh by by the way real quick public
service announcement i am double
vaccinated
but i don't think you should yell at
every person who doesn't want to get the
vaccine
[Applause]
there they are get them
all black people got nervous
no i'm being serious dude i don't think
you should yell at a person just because
they don't want to get the vaccine
unless they're fat
now i got a problem with you
oh now you care about your health
now when you can kill more than just you
all of a sudden you're health conscious
you're on four blood pressure
medications and now you don't trust big
pharma
your blood type is lipitor and now you
don't trust medicine huh
[Applause]
look if you are against a vaccine but
you are a personal trainer who watches
everything you put in your body at least
you're consistent
but if you're about to lose your foot
anyway
take the shot
talking all about i'm worried about my
quality of life you can't even walk a
flight of steps
quality of life you sleep with a cpap
machine
i don't know the vaccine could kill me
so could a nap
[ __ ] you talking about
cause i'm tired of listening to these
fat [ __ ]
yeah you know i've been doing a lot of
reading online oh what a surprise the
fat guy sat at his computer for three
days straight
it's funny you can read all that [ __ ]
but you can never seem to read nutrition
facts
right there on the box of butter just
that escapes you
[ __ ] them lame-ass excuses from fat
people
fat [ __ ] like i don't know what
they put in those things you're eating
flamin hot cheetos dawg
you got any clue what red lake 40 is you
fat [ __ ]
let that laugh out dawg go ahead bro i
see white dude's happy
you laughing like you got a fat family
member
see how he laughing he knows
i'm just saying don't you want to feel
something in your left arm before you
grab that [ __ ] in the middle of
your heart attack
it would be nice to do this and not have
to die at the end of it yeah well that's
a little sore as opposed to
call my hole once
there's only one form of privilege i
believe in
white female privilege
[Music]
see how scared you all got in that kind
of something
that's the power they have them [ __ ]
are like voldemort
[Music]
oh no don't say their name
they'll write a blog you'll disappear
hey don't hide your face when you laugh
bro [ __ ] these [ __ ]
every minority that complains about
white men ladies is just trying to [ __ ]
you i'm not that guy
but i don't have a problem with your
privilege i think it's a good thing i
think you should teach your privilege
globally because a lot of women could
use white female privilege
listen i'm indian i read the metoo
accounts from women in india
it was horrifying my stomach hurt you
couldn't believe the atrocities these
women had to suffer
then i read the metoo accounts from
white women in america
[Music]
it just don't hit the same
i'm not saying white women didn't have
to suffer i know there were some
terrible stories but there was a lot of
you like oh you have no idea how hard it
is for us
i cannot even walk down the street
without men saying
hi okay
oh that's good oh my god that's so funny
that's what you think street harassment
looks like oh my goodness
do you know what street harassment looks
like in india
like this
[Music]
yeah right at a certain point
weren't all you guys like dude please
talk to me
tell me i got a fat ass i don't care
just say anything
brown [ __ ] got ptsd in the middle
i'm on a train again
again i am not trying to marginalize
what all white women had to go through i
read those harvey weinstein accounts
that was [ __ ] awful dude
these white actresses were like harvey
weinstein made me perform oral sex to be
in his movie and that's [ __ ] up dude
my first thought when i read that is
[ __ ] that guy he's a monster i hope he
spends the rest of his life in prison
and his afterlife in hell [ __ ] that guy
yup absolutely
absolutely [ __ ] that [ __ ] yo
that was my first thought
[Applause]
my second thought
[Applause]
is he still casting
[Applause]
laughs
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm just saying dude a movie i'm gonna
be honest i don't even need a movie i
will suck dick for sitcoms
for a movie i'll [ __ ] this guy
tell my wife about it
babe where you going putting on the
condom and getting us a condo
and again guys i am not trying to
downplay the importance of the metoo
movement it is easily the most important
movement in our lifetimes i would never
try to downplay that significance
i will say
the first few weeks i thought me too
was just all of us talking about things
we would also do to be in a movie
was a little embarrassing
on twitter like you were subject to
being a vengeance me too
i want to send a [ __ ] message to
anybody that looks like me
you don't deserve
anything
this idea you walk around with that you
will deserve certain things you don't
deserve a single [ __ ] thing your
parents our parents who came here
literally with six [ __ ] dollars
didn't get here because they thought
anybody owed them dick they came over
here because they worked because they
were the best of the [ __ ] best that's
how they got here then they came here
with six [ __ ] bucks in a country
where language they didn't understand in
a culture they didn't understand and
they built from [ __ ] nothing because
they knew i don't deserve [ __ ] i get
what i earn i eat what i kill how the
[ __ ] we lost that so quickly disgusts me
and we need to cut that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out you don't deserve [ __ ]
go get it go be great like your [ __ ]
parents who are hopefully still walking
around and looking at you every day
that's all i need to say